l'année touche à sa fin je voudrais
qu'on fasse un petit tour pour regarder
quel est le smartphone de l'année en
2022 quel smartphone a vraiment bluffé
alors on va regarder un peu tous les
smartphones que j'ai vu je vous le dis
on va parler ici uniquement des
smartphones que j'ai eu entre les mains
que j'ai pu prendre que j'ai pu
manipuler travailler je vais vous dire à
la fin de cette vidéo parce que il y a
plein de choses à venir raconter quel
est mon smartphone préféré sur toute
l'année 2022 on y va
cette vidéo est totalement subjective
c'est-à-dire c'est vraiment je vous le
dis une fois de plus ce sont uniquement
des produits que j'ai pu tester il y en
a plein qui sont sortis il y en a
certains que j'ai vu d'autres que j'ai
pas vu j'ai vu les plus gros je crois
que j'ai vu les plus importants et là
maintenant quelques-uns fatalement que
j'ai pas pu prendre en main donc dans
cette sélection on va essayer de faire
un petit peu le point sur tout ce qui
est sorti cette année on va pas se faire
une grosse tartine de smartphone parce
que vous voyez la liste est longue et la
liste est grande j'ai stabilité des
choses donc ça il allait un peu vite que
vous puissiez pas mettre un arrêt sur
image et lire non et puis il y a aussi
des innovations des smartphones que j'ai
trouvé aussi super intéressant parce
qu'ils novembre et que j'ai mis un petit
peu en dehors j'essaie de retracer la
chronologie voir ce que c'était passé
toute cette année avec différents
smartphones effectivement ils vont pas
toujours dans la même catégorie il y a
des smartphones qui vont coûter une
centaine d'euros d'autres qui vont
coûter plus de 1000 euros donc
fatalement il joue pas avec les mêmes
armes mais il y en a vraiment qui pour
moi se détache en tout cas il y a un
côté plus émotionnel avec je vais vous
expliquer vous allez comprendre alors
cette année a été extrêmement riche en
smartphone on a vu arriver pas mal de
choses beaucoup d'innovation notamment
du côté du pliable mais pas que et vous
allez voir que c'était super intéressant
l'année tu es quand même vachement cool
j'espère qu'en 2023 ce sera aussi
chouette donc alors moi j'ai débuté
l'année on vous parlant du Galaxy s21f
j'ai bien aimé ce smartphone très bien
très bon rapport qualité prix Samsung
est très efficace mais c'est pas celui
qui m'a un petit peu
iPad plus après sont arrivés les S22
vous savez c'est les smartphones les
plus haut de gamme de Samsung pour
l'année 2022 S22 S22 + 22 ultra alors je
vous ai bien aimé aussi pas mal le S22
ultra m'a beaucoup plu d'ailleurs j'ai
fait un comparatif entre le S22 ultra le
pixel 7 pro et l'iPhone 14 pro max sur
ma chaîne si vous avez pas vu aller
jeter un œil parce que en réalité ils
ont chacun leurs avantages inconvénients
il y en a pas réellement qui se détache
même si le S2 ultra en condition de
faible luminosité et la nuit j'ai eu des
choses très très fous folles des choses
folles c'est même plus parler français
j'ai eu des résultats dingue et
d'ailleurs j'avais été faire une vidéo
avec Samsung où on était parti pendant
de l'urbex et ça m'avait absolument
scotché donc ça c'est vrai que c'est
c'est un très joli smartphone que j'ai
beaucoup aimé en 2022 même si c'est pas
le smartphone le plus coup de cœur que
j'ai pu avoir cette année alors après
sont arrivés plein d'autres smartphones
je pense notamment à la gamme redmi note
11 de Xiaomi font du très bon rapport
qualité-prix qui vont bien c'est un peu
des smartphones courants parce que vous
voyez on va vraiment se détacher des
smartphones qui sont un peu plus
exceptionnels souvent forcément bah les
plus chers parce que c'est là où les
marques ils mettent le plus de budget là
où il y a le plus de moyens et puis vous
avez les smartphones je dirais qu'on va
pouvoir acheter lorsqu'on va renouveler
sur du milieu de gamme de l'entrée de
gamètes pas mal qui sont vraiment sympa
j'ai bien aimé aussi le oneplus Lord CE2
que tu es aussi plutôt pas mal même si
bon c'est vrai qu'il manque un petit
truc mais il est cool Rilly aussi a fait
de très jolis smartphones cette année je
pense notamment
au rythme vachement bien super apoc a
été pris très speaké qui marchait très
cool on a eu aussi le oppo finding 5 Pro
qui est un super smartphone et que j'ai
beaucoup aimé finding 5 aussi très bien
poco X4 pro ok 5G cool il y en a qui m'a
vraiment surpris cette année qui est
aussi un un de mes coups de cœur hein
c'est le Honor Magic 4 pro alors je vous
en ai déjà parlé au nord revient un peu
de très loin parce que avant ils étaient
avec Huawei on sait quoi oui il y a
quelques années je crois que c'est en
2018 a perdu les services Google c'était
très très compliqué pour eux du coup ils
ont développé la galerie enfin bref
toutes leurs solutions dont on a déjà
beaucoup parlé sur la chaîne et Honor
s'est détaché de Huawei et ça leur a
permis de récupérer les services Google
et de revenir beaucoup plus fort là où
on aura été juste la marque jeune de
Huawei aujourd'hui c'est une marque
complète à 360 degrés hop là c'est qui
me parle c'est une tablette je crois que
coucou
360 degrés avec des produits très haut
de gamme notamment ce Honor Magic 4 pro
qui est super bon et très très bon en
photo il marche vachement bien il y a
plein de techno donc ça fait vraiment
partie des smartphones coup de coeur là
on se retrace un petit peu un panorama
et puis je vous dirai à la fin qu'elles
sont vraiment ceux qui m'ont qui m'ont
marqué fort le oneplus 10 pro j'ai été
un peu déçu au niveau de la photo par le
oneplus 10 pro je trouvais que c'était
la deuxième année qu'ils avaient à
partenariat avec un seul Blade et je
trouve que cette année ils ont moins
bien bossé et là où un seul Blade a
vraiment mieux bosser avec oppo ils ont
vraiment moins bien bossé avec oneplus
c'est un peu déceptible c'est un peu
dommage après bon toujours pareil le pot
comme 4 pro qui était pas mal alors
Xiaomi 12 12 Pro bien très joli
évolution également du côté de chez
Xiaomi alors vous savez aujourd'hui
Xiaomi c'est une marque qui est très
forte dans le milieu il en train de
gamme avec notamment la gamme redmi note
les smartphones les plus haut de gamme
qu'ils ont encore un petit peu de mal
parce que quand les gens tout de suite
se disent ok moi je veux acheter un
smartphone j'ai un budget 1000 balles
quelque chose comme ça il pense pas tout
de suite Xiaomi Moïse ils ont pas encore
réussi à avoir le switch d'image
extrêmement haut de gamme pour autant
avec le Xiaomi 12S ultra que j'ai
également vu dont je vous ai déjà parlé
c'est une vraie petite bombe en photo
c'est dingue le partenariat avec Leica
qui est arrivé cette qui va je pense
continuer à convaincre et permettre à
Xiaomi de monter encore plus en gamme et
puis les Xiaomi 13 et 13 pro qui ont été
présentés en Chine il y a pas longtemps
dont je vous ai déjà fait une vidéo sur
ma chaîne allez jeter un coup d’œil vous
allez voir c'est vraiment super cool ça
on en reparle l'année prochaine donc
pensez à vous abonner et actionner la
cloche pour tout savoir dès que je vous
paraît effectivement que c'est nouveau
smartphone alors on a eu du côté de chez
Samsung la valeur sûre le truc si vous
voulez un bon smartphone bon rapport
qualité prix avec un super objectif
photo le Galaxy a53 qui est très très
bien est arrivé également cette année à
nouvelle version de l'iPhone se l'iPhone
se c'est la troisième version de 2022
qui est bien ok que un bon iPhone qui
marche plutôt pas mal côté performance
on est le redmi GT de pro qui était
aussi un super smartphone qui a vraiment
envoyé du bois Motorola qui est bien
plutôt sympa avec son ex 30 pro alors
j'ai bien aimé le design j'ai encore un
peu de mal moto en photo faut vraiment
qu'ils améliorent cette partie là pour
vraiment venir réussir à choper
davantage côté perf on va dire gaming
alors c'est pas trop un smartphone qu'on
va venir acheter parce qu'il est pas
distribué en France c'est le Red Magic 7
pro c'est une petite bombe un taux de
rafraîchissement de 144 Hertz bref mais
bon c'est vrai que c'est pas le
smartphone on va voir en France autre
produit que j'ai bien aimé que j'ai
trouvé assez marrant même s'il était pas
fou fou c'est le vivo V23 le vivo V23 il
avait un truc très particulier au niveau
du dos lorsqu'un dos avec un des aspects
photos chroniques on pouvait moduler la
couleur du dos bon il y avait un côté un
peu rigolo ça c'est chouette ça ça m'a
bien plu aussi parce que je trouve que
vivos bouge vachement ils ont fait
celui-là et autres rêves de vivo que
j'ai ici là que j'ai noté c'est le vivo
le X80 pro j'ai adoré le X80 pro parce
que pareil vous savez vivo c'est eux qui
ont créé le niveau techno le capteur
d'empreinte sous l'écran et ils font des
choses absolument incroyables et là avec
le X80 pro alors ils reprennent un peu
l'ADN déjà du X 60 qu'on avait avant
c'est-à-dire une caméra game ball donc
vous prenez votre Smartphone vous le
tournez comme vous voulez ça ne bouge
pas donc ça permet d'avoir un maintien
de l'horizon c'est pas bien d'avoir une
super stabilisation ça permet de faire
plein de choses dans le point de vue
sauf donc ça c'est très très cool et en
plus de ça ils ont créé ils l'ont montré
pour la première fois c'est un énorme
capteur d'empreinte digitale ce qui fait
que lorsque vous voulez venir scanner
votre doigt vous le posez une fois et ça
déverrouille ça leur permet sur leur
très gros sparti centrale et bien
d'avoir des petits raccourcis vous
pouvez le dire attribuer pour ouvrir
rapidement un Google avec votre
empreinte digitale ou un facebook ou ce
que vous voulez donc ça c'est très cool
et une fois de vivo c'est une marque qui
prend un peu son temps qui est arrivé il
y a pas très très longtemps en France
mais qui est un mastodonte en Asie et
qui a des supers produits donc je pense
qu'on va continuer à en parler et avec
de belles innovations qui vont arriver
l'année prochaine alors autre produit
très cool c'est plus un produit courant
c'est le oppo on a vu le Rhino 7 le
Rhino 8 alors tous les rayons ne sort
pas en France parce qu'ils ont sorti
deux fois par an donc c'est vrai qu'en
France on soit une génération le réunion
7 est assez marrant parce qu'il recyclé
un peu la caméra microscope qu'on avait
vu avec le oppo x c'était le 3 je t'ai
pas de bêtises ou le 2 je sais plus que
tu es plutôt pas mal voilà ça c'est
rigolo au nord avec son X7 et X8 aussi
gros voilà rien de 1009 ok ça marchait
alors un produit qui est un peu atypique
c'est le Sony Xperia one marque 4 parce
que autant j'ai toujours pensé que Sony
était trop un pied de côté et il était
trop démarqués par rapport à ce qui se
faisait c'était compliqué au niveau de
la photo de la vidéo autant ils sont
simplifiés au niveau de la photo parce
que vous avez une app qui peut tout
faire autant au niveau de la vidéo vous
avez trois applications c'est un bordel
absolu mais l'idée de Sony c'est de se
dire ok on est une énorme boîte
japonaise on a aussi bien les télé
Bravia on a les caméras avec Sony Alpha
d'ailleurs je suis en train filmer avec
un alpha tout de suite il y a l'audio
avec les cases notamment le WH médical 5
bref ils ont tout ils ont le cinéma ils
ont la musique ils ont tout ils sont dit
on va tout réunir de notre smartphone
alors le message est un peu compliqué
parce que il y a un peu trop de choses
c'est un peu fourre-tout mais pour
autant ils prennent les choses un peu à
contre-pied de ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui dans l'industrie et si on
veut une marque qui est différente et
qu'on veut un très bon smartphone parce
que ça reste un bon smartphone mais qui
est différent on peut aller chez Sony
pour autant c'est pas forcément fait
pour tout le monde néanmoins c'est un
smartphone qui fonctionne plutôt bien
alors après on a vu d'autres produits
assez cool du côté de chez poco le xc4
GT le F4 bien pas trop orienté photo
mais plus orienter gaming et performance
donc si on veut ça c'est bien il y a un
smartphone qui va aussi beaucoup plus
cette année qui est plutôt dans le
milieu de gamme hein milieu haut du
milieu de gamme c'est le nothing phone
one pourquoi parce que j'ai beaucoup
parlé avec l'équipe de Nothing et en
fait ils viennent vraiment proposer
quelque chose d'autre au niveau de
l'expérience alors ça reste un
smartphone attention on est sur un truc
qu'on connaît bon voilà c'est un
smartphone un beau milieu haut de gamme
mais pour autant il y a un design qui
est différent il raconte une autre
histoire et une autre façon de venir
choper le truc je trouve ça très chaud
d'ailleurs j'ai encore un produit donc
il faut je vous parle de Nothing je peux
que je vous en parle très bientôt parce
que je les ai là sur les écouteurs à
côté un peu lipstick rouge à lèvres je
trouve assez marrant donc on se
regardera ça donc ça ça m'a vachement
plus je trouve ça très cool du lapin
nociné que j'ai beaucoup aimé ce
smartphone autre produit que j'ai
beaucoup aimé aussi c'est le rock phone
6 pro de Asus parce que si vous voulez
un smartphone de gaming je pense que
c'est le produit qu'il faut acheter
alors attention il y a des accessoires
ça coûte cher ça coûte très cher si vous
voulez vous équiper mais si vous voulez
un super smartphone extrêmement
performant qui va être un peu moyen en
photo très honnêtement c'est pas ouf
mais bon voilà et ben le Asus le rock
phone 6 pro c'est une petite bombe alors
ils ont sorti le zenfone 9 c'est leur
smartphone plus monsieur madame tout le
monde pour autant Asus c'est pas eux qui
vont le plus de smartphone donc ils sont
dit ok comment est-ce qu'on peut se
démarquer ils ont dit bah on va aller
sur un petit format ils ont fait un plus
petit format avec le zenfone 9 qui est
plutôt mignon je trouve franchement
plutôt mignon qui est plutôt équilibré
qui marche bien donc bon ça peut aussi
être un truc pas mal si on va aller sur
une valeur sûre je dirais plus dans le
milieu de gamme ce qui m'a beaucoup plu
c'était le pixel 6a de Google pourquoi
parce que ils vont toujours plus loin au
niveau de la photo ils améliorent leur
smartphone plusieurs capteurs et puis
surtout la phot qui computationnel
c'est-à-dire toute l'intelligence
artificielle et toutes les capacités de
calcul que vous avez de Google derrière
qui en fait un smartphone absolument
exceptionnel à un tarif très maîtrisé
donc c'est un super rapport qualité-prix
donc ça j'ai vachement bien aimé et
c'est souvent le smartphone que je vais
venir recommander pour des personnes qui
me disent ouais un budget un peu mais je
veux un bon appareil photo pixel 6a 100
% Android ça marche vachement bien
Hotmail plutôt rigolo le oneplus 10T
alors c'est pareil oneplus à une année
un peu en demi-tain on va voir où est-ce
qu'ils vont aller l'année prochaine Sony
Xperia 5 market on reste sur du haut de
gamme on est un petit peu en dessous du
Xperia one market smartphone qui m'a
bien plu aussi c'est le Honor 70 que
j'ai là parce que j'ai fait une vidéo
sur Honor il y a pas longtemps le Honor
70 qui a un très très bon milieu de
gamme avec des fonctions un peu à part
ils ont mis le mode solo cut qui est un
peu rigolo qui change pas bien la face
du monde mais qui est marrant mais ça
reste un très bon smartphone donc si
vous voulez aller chez Honor et que vous
avez pas le budget pour m'acheter le
Magic 4 Pro vous pouvez prendre le Honor
70 alors les sorties également chez
Apple 4 nouveau smartphone cette année
j'ai pu en avoir que un seul c'est ici
l'iPhone 14 pro max que j'aime bien que
je trouve qu'il y a un mon smartphone
alors vous savez chez Apple tout est
très équilibré c'est vrai qu'il pourrait
aller encore plus loin ils en ont
franchement sous le capot de ce qu'ils
ont ici mais ils veulent proposer une
expérience totalement équilibrée et
juste donc on a un smartphone qui sera
très bon en photo qui sera très bon en
vidéo qui sera très performant qui sera
très bon partout avec une autonomie qui
est très bonne donc tout est OK et tout
va bien donc là-dessus il y a pas de
surprise pour autant ça coûte quand même
relativement cher alors c'est avec
l'iPhone 13 on s'est dit l'iPhone 13 je
dis l'iPhone 13 donc je pense à l'iPhone
14 parce qu'en fait c'est quasiment la
même chose vous avez un cœur de GPU en
plus bon l'iPhone 13 iPhone 14 même
combat je trouvais le 14 plus
intéressant mais j'ai pas pu la voir
donc j'ai pas pu le tester donc je vous
en parle pas mais voilà donc ça c'est un
bon smartphone également Xiaomi 12 t pro
qui était aussi super intéressant que
j'ai bien aimé très bon smartphone alors
j'étais vraiment surpris par les pixels
7 et Pixel 7 Pro notamment le pixel 7
Pro parce que ça va vachement plus loin
que ce qu'on avait avec le pixel 6 pro
j'étais un peu en mi-temps je trouvais
des fois Google elle est un petit peu
trop loin au niveau de la photographie
computationnelle je vous l'ai dit avec
le pixel 6 pro des fois c'est un peu
tout meute sur certains effets ça marche
bien attention et je trouve qu'avec le
pixel 7 Pro ça va plus loin c'est plus
équilibré c'est beau ça marche très très
bien donc sur votre très joli smartphone
expérience 100% Android avec de très
belles photos pixelset pro là-dessus il
y a pas de déception voilà un peu pour
les smartphones un peu standards que je
suis venu tester et avant de vous dire
lequel m'a vraiment le plus plus cette
année en 2022 je vous parlais un peu des
smartphones à innovation parce qu'il y
en a eu quelques-uns que j'ai vu cette
année qui sortent un peu l'ordinaire
notamment du côté du pliant on va
regarder avec le oppo finden alors le
oppo finden c'est pas un smartphone qui
est commercialisé c'est un concept que
je vous ai présenté en début d'année
c'est un super smartphone pourquoi parce
qu'en fait c'est vous savez dans l'idée
aujourd'hui dans ce qu'on a sur le
marché français on va surtout avoir un
seul et grand acteur qui vend des
smartphones qui split c'est Samsung on
va avoir le Galaxy Z flip 4 le grand
smartphone où on vient réduire
l'encombrement pour le mettre dans la
poche c'est le smartphone qui cartonne Z
flip 3 Netflix cam je pense qu'ils en
vendent des sauts c'est un smartphone
qui est génial et qui cartonne
réellement et on a le Galaxy 7 folle de
4 le Galaxy Z fold 4 c'est l'inverse
vous avez un smartphone vous l'ouvrez et
vous augmentez l'espace utile je trouve
ces smartphones très chouettes c'est
vrai que j'ai plus moi personnellement
sur le zflip 3 voir le zflip 4 alors les
Philippe 4 il a un peu plus loin au
niveau de la photo que je flippe 3 mais
d'un point de vue logiciel c'est la même
chose donc on aura plus de performances
et on sera mieux en photo avec le zip 4
néanmoins si vous n'avez pas le budget
pour le flip 4 vous allez sur Delphi 3
vous aurez la même expérience même si
certaines choses vous vous irez un petit
peu un petit peu moins loin ça j'ai
vachement aimé et je vous dis le beau
findn j'ai trouvé intéressant pourquoi
parce qu'en fait là où je trouve que des
fois le Z fold 4 est un petit peu grand
très très grand et ben le finden il a un
format un peu plus carré un peu plus
maîtrisé donc ça j'ai vachement aimé
donc avoir si ça arrivera j'ai vu aussi
le Huawei le mate x162 je trouvais assez
intéressant également plutôt pas mal
fichu alors un concept de smartphone que
je vous ai présenté en début d'année
c'est le TCL Chicago alors ça c'est une
copie absolue du Galaxy dead flip 4 de
Samsung vous êtes plus 3 parce que vous
étiez 4 ça fait pas encore sorti enfin
bref même combat pour autant tester elle
m'a dit bah ce smartphone on va pas le
sortir aujourd'hui parce que si on
devait le sortir il coûterait un peu
trop cher et nous on veut des tarifs
extrêmement maîtrisés donc en tout cas
ils savent faire donc peut-être qu'on
verra arriver ce concept de smartphone
pliant j'étais celle là t'arrive
beaucoup plus bas j'y crois réellement
donc ça peut être chouette et puis deux
smartphones dont je vous ai parlé il y a
pas très très longtemps Xiaomi le mix
fold 2 très chouette smartphone j'ai
beaucoup aimé je trouve que le format
est très intéressant je préfère l'écran
extérieur du mixol de 2 par rapport à
celui du Galaxy Z fold 4 de Samsung
vraiment super bien je l'ai beaucoup
aimé je sais pas s'il arrivera en France
mais bon en tout cas j'aime bien il y en
a un qui va arriver en France
probablement en février l'année
prochaine c'est le Honor c'est le Magic
vs c'est la deuxième version de leur
smartphone pliant à Honor et qui pour le
coup et aussi très sympa et plutôt bien
fichu donc vous voyez il y a toutes ces
innovations qu'on voit là il y a aussi
le Motorola le Razer de 2022 qu'on peut
venir mettre également ici que plutôt
sympa plutôt pas mal fichu mais c'est
vrai que si je mets en face un zflip 4
et un Motorola Heather et je vais
fatalement aller sur le zip 4 que je
vais trouver mieux meilleur en photo il
a beaucoup plus d'avantages même si un
Motorola est toujours là il y a toujours
l'innovation ça c'est chouette et donc
on continuera à regarder ça l'année
prochaine donc voilà un peu pour tous
ces smartphones que j'ai vu cette année
alors il y en a vraiment un qui pour moi
se détache je voulais déjà dit en fait
c'est marrant parce que j'ai fait une
vidéo au milieu de l'année en vous
disant mon smartphone préféré au milieu
de l'année 2022 c'est celui-là et bien
ça n'a pas changé il a pas été détrôné
c'est le oppo findige 5 Pro qui pour moi
reste le meilleur compromis c'est pas le
meilleur compromis c'est que j'ai
vraiment eu un coup de cœur au niveau de
la photo parce que je trouve qu'ils font
un truc qui est absolument dingue au
niveau de la photo regardez par exemple
je vous montre cette photo là cette
photo elle a été prise à Roland-Garros
alors je donne un petit peu de contexte
j'ai été invité à Roland Garros vous
savez que oppo si vous le savez en tout
cas je vous le dis au pot et partenaire
de Roland-Garros on les voit hein au
bord du coup on va leur nom et sur un
des derniers jours j'étais invité je
suis allé deux fois cette année avec eux
c'est super chouette et je suis venu
avec Léo Léo qui est mon ami et cadreur
avec qui je travaille de temps en temps
et ils ont fait un concours ils ont dit
ben écoutez celui qui fera la meilleure
photo de service et bien repartira avec
un smartphone et je savais que Léo il
adoré ce smartphone donc Léo il est
photographe et donc du coup ils ont
passé un tout le monde un smartphone je
l'ai laissé faire moi je vais regarder
le match OK et du coup il a fait une
photo de dingue et c'est lui qui a gagné
d'ailleurs qui a gagné le smartphone il
était hyper heureux et cette photo elle
est folle parce qu'en fait elle pourrait
presque être fait par un réflexe alors
autant on voit qu'il y a des moments
c'est assez imprécis parce que regarde
un peu de flou sur certains endroits au
niveau de la balle au niveau mais pour
autant la photo elle a une couleur et
elle a ressenti ça trouve très douce ça
trouve très belle et les images en règle
générale qu'on vient shooter avec ce
smartphone je trouve qu'il y a un côté
qui se rapproche de la douceur qu'on
pourrait avoir avec un réflexe et c'est
pour ça que ce smartphone j'aime
beaucoup au-delà qui soit performant
au-delà qui est l'expérience logicielle
elle est super au-delà que on a une
belle autonomie en termes de photos je
le trouve au dessus des autres même si
le téléobjectif est pas parfait vous
voyez il y en a d'autres qui seront
meilleurs et que tu es l'objectif elle a
d'autres qui seront meilleurs sur plein
d'autres choses mais je trouve qu'il y a
une émotion qui se dégage de ce
smartphone avec le capteur principal
donc pour moi aujourd'hui en tout cas
dans tout ce que j'ai vu le oppo finding
5 Pro je le place en haut j'ai adoré
également je mettrai la deuxième
position je pense le Honor Magic 4 pro
parce que j'ai trouvé absolument dingue
aussi au niveau de la photo au-delà de
toute la performance quand on est dans
le très haut de gamme de toute façon les
smartphones ils ont quasiment tous les
mêmes processeurs ils ont les mêmes
techno de RAM les mêmes techno
d'écriture donc ce qui va changer un peu
c'est comment est-ce qu'ils vont
travailler d'un point de vue logiciel en
se basant sur un Android si on est
là-dessus après si on est sur un iPhone
c'est encore un peu différent mais voyez
c'est vraiment ça qui compte j'ai trouvé
le Magic 4 pro génial donc voilà un peu
je dirais les les deux grosses
smartphones le finding 5 Pro le Magic 4
pro qui est quand même en dessous après
il y en a plein d'autres que j'ai aimé
je vous ai raconté je vous ai dit
pourquoi est-ce que je les ai aimés ça
veut pas dire que les autres sont pas
bon c'est très subjectif une fois de
plus c'est le ressenti puis là je vous
parle typiquement de photos donc c'est
l'émotion que va dégager un rendu
photographique je l'ai fait également en
vidéo lorsqu'on a fait des tests
automobiles avec Léo on a utilisé
souvent pour venir filmer sur des plans
extérieurs lorsqu'on roulait le find
Dick 5 Pro on l'a fait également avec
l'iPhone 13 pro max que j'avais à
l'époque et avec le fighting pro avec le
fanick 5 Pro et les super bon l'image
elle est belle quoi donc voilà ça c'est
vraiment un truc que j'ai aimé donc
voilà un peu pour ce retour d'expérience
sur mes smartphones préférés de 2022 je
sais pas vous d'ailleurs alors j'imagine
que vous avez pas eu l'opportunité de
venir tester tous ces smartphones donc
vous aurez peut-être pas cette vision un
peu d'ensemble mais on a de très très
jolis produits cette année on peut se
dire franchement les constructeurs ont
très bien bossé pixel 7 Pro j'ai adoré
l'iPhone 14 pro max je continue d'adorer
j'aime bien le nothing fun je vous ai
dit pixel 6a c'est un très très joli
produit Galaxy Z flip 4 très joli
produit extrêmement canon et puis dans
le milieu de gamme il y a aussi plein de
jolies smartphones à droite à gauche
Galaxy a53 du côté de chez Xiaomi il y a
de très jolies choses bref donc voilà un
peu pour ce portrait pour l'année 2022
on regardera encore les smartphones
rassurez-vous en 2023 il va y avoir de
très très jolies choses et ce que j'ai
déjà vu me plaît beaucoup donc je ne
serai pas surpris d'être encore surpris
en 2023 je vous embrasse prenez soin de
vous à bientôt Ciao
[Musique]